president biden's taking a knife in the
backs of border patrol his dhs is
preparing to discipline multiple
horseback mounted agents in connection
with the infamous whipping hoax
which saw border patrol agents accused
of hitting haitian migrants at the texas
border last september
turns out
those were just horse reigns
and those agents were cleared of
criminal wrongdoing because they didn't
do anything wrong
but now biden's going after him for
administrative violations
it's not a surprise
after how the administration and the
media falsely smeared these guys
remember
it's outrageous i promise you those
people will pay we understand and agree
that this has been an incredibly
heart-wrenching issue we've been
discussing
those disturbing images of u.s border
patrol agents on horseback inhumanely
corralling haitians at the texas border
i was outraged by it
it was horrible and
and deeply troubling
border patrol agents are fuming with one
saying to fox the so-called punishment
is effing bs whatever that means
dana um
joe and comma they don't believe in due
process do they
i find this in the long list of
embarrassing things for the
administration this to me goes to the
top because it inc incorporates all the
things that are wrong they've never been
outside of the eastern seaboard so they
don't know what it's like to actually
ride a horse and utilize a horse they
convicted these guys before they had
even investigated them when they found
out that oh oh it was horse reigns oh
they would they didn't do anything wrong
they still didn't pull it back they
don't deserve anything but an apology
all of these agents that were on
horseback that day they've been on desk
duty since last september we are down 2
000 agents at the border do you think
that's a good idea maybe like tell
everybody like cool your heels and now
to add insult to injury to add
administrative violations what could
they possibly be and the president could
use his discretion here mr empathy he
could call the department of homeland
security and say let it go
let these guys get back to work but
instead they have to come up with some
trumped-up charges like some third world
dictator that makes me furious he's
probably afraid of his base judge don't
you think
if he goes soft why would they remember
they wouldn't remember this was all a
media hoax to begin with it's all it's
all theater it's all theater joe biden
is about theater he's about making
things up he's about the last two blocks
about the lies i mean it's just
unbelievable look isn't it the job of
these border patrol agents to protect or
to prevent immigrants from entering i
mean what is their job if you don't want
them to do that don't put them on a
horse and don't put them at the border
but the truth is that the the border
patrol they're afraid of doing their job
for fear that they're going to be on
national television they're going to
lose their job and so what they're doing
is they're doing nothing the mexican
cartels are laughing at us as china is
sending fentanyl the cartels know that
the border agents are afraid to exercise
any kind of control they're too busy
monitoring this surge to even look for
fentanyl and the bottom line is that
it's just part of letting the world into
the united states when is enough enough
all right so they'll come up with some
kind of administrative
nonsense and you know just to create
what didn't they do couldn't they sue
the president for defamation no there's
a sovereign immunity no
no he's always protesting
geraldo if these border patrol agents
had hoisted the haitian
onto the back of the horse and then
galloped him into the country
joe probably would have seen that and
put a congressional medal of honor
nonsense
i defer to dana who is very measured in
her emotions and when she says this is
the worst thing that she's seen i
respect that deeply because i know you
don't
actually baby formula is really bad too
but uh let me say about this first i
want to say something about the haitians
the haitians get the short end of the
stick every time no matter what when it
comes to immigration they have to they
flee haiti where the poverty is is
extreme and the government is
dysfunctional and corrupt they have and
so they go from the island of espanola
they go to cuba and rickety boats they
get somehow into central america or into
south america by boat then they walk
through the darian gap through the
jungle they they
they risk everything and then they get
here and then they get set back at a
much higher rate than any other nation
haitians get screwed
now
in terms of the border patrol it's true
i was raised in new york city or lived
on the either coast most of my life i've
ridden horses i've watched the border
patrol but this is you must admit when
you look at this visual put up a shot
put up any of the shots of this series
but you have four grown-ups and they're
riding these big horses and you got
these people who just walked 5 000 miles
risking everything and now there's big
monkeys how would you handle it macho
guys you can't even give these guys i
give you memories you know why because
you can't apologize
i am delighted that they are not being
critical
i am absolutely don't don't tell me what
i am feeling great you can have your
opinion but don't have my opinion
i i married couples
i uh i think this whole sorry chapter is
better off in the rearview because
you're not that horses anytime
you wish it would be in the rear view
mirror but no it's in the front view
right now i think the person who leaked
this story is a genius because here's
the thing we don't know what the
punishment is and the reason why we
don't know what the punishment is is
because it's been sitting on somebody's
desk did somebody here
force the government's hand because we
kept asking okay you said you were going
to investigate and punish these evil
whipsters if they were guilty now we
found out that they were innocent and we
took so where is the vindication where's
the vindication and the apology they
didn't want to do that so somebody there
leaked it to force the hand of this
administration to actually man up and
apologize i think it's actually worse
than lying i think that biden actually
is so out of touch he thought this was
real and this was fed to him by again
woke staffers you got to remember this
was the only story about the border that
the media and the democrats covered not
the coyotes not the children in cages
because it wasn't under trump not the
sexual assaults not the drug trafficking
they only cared about the border when
they found a suitable villain and the
suitable villain was law enforcement the
people who are older that you say you
love so much and they get stabbed in the
back call it a macho cowboy i i stab
them in the back i stay up trump in the
back who else do i stare in there
first of all i stay up in the front i
don't know you you you always praise
somebody and then you say how how
respect would you like you know
what if that little haitian kid was your
kid um i was did he steal something and
was he a kid i think he was an adult and
steal something
well one of one of the reasons that they
were trying to push them back and they
were trying to get that guy had just
stolen the bag of a woman who had said
the investigation and also the person
you just
respected the person you deeply
respected geraldo said that all right
using those horses in that manner
were everywhere geraldo hi everyone i'm
brian kilmeade i want you to do me a
favor i want you to click to subscribe
to the fox news youtube page this is the
only way that i know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on fox
you can get it all here on youtube so
subscribe right now